you're a hero you know that in fact she
was so much of a hero that she got
awarded and I didn't know exactly what
this was up until last week she's an
MBE member of the British Empire yes
what you would
think what no she went to Buckingham
Palace she went to Buckingham Palace and
and uh William actually gave it to you
right yeah I did you William there are
pictures to prove this she was and
Victoria dressed me and my mom you know
she put a split in my dress here so he
had to pin it right there which was a
bit embarrassing well was it was that
obviously if she designed a dress for I
didn't realize that the slit was like
booby but Victoria did so was was it an
I was William was it meant so that
William could enjoy the moment as much
as you I think she did that on purpose
the little but it looks really
great though you did look amazing the
dress was nice and your mom was there
with you yeah she was nervous well
because you into the bathroom for little
pop
offs pop offs in nervous poops no no no
pop offs are farts farts I know but
there is such thing as nervous poops too
when you get nervous when your mother
gets nervous she farts well she did she
did in Buckingham palette yeah and I had
to spray air freshener do you bring air
it's there well hairspray Buckingham
hairspray yeah just to disguise the
smell I know but it was just
embarrassing if anybody else went in
there so this went I'm glad to be here
yeah no I just love the idea that it
went from being awarded like that is one
of the highest honors in the world let
alone in in Britain it go to your mother
farting in the bathroom MB orb and then
you get kned and stuff like that don't
just make at the top are you working
towards being kned well the thing is you
can't decide if you get an MB or an OB
do you want to ask she got it for what
did you get it for for bringing
awareness to domestic violence and stuff
like that quite seriously
hey
he